[Music]
god damn right we're gonna talk about
the Hannah Montana movie because that's
what thirty seven-year-old men do they
talk about Hannah Montana like mad no
regrets okay that's not entirely true
there's quite a bit of regret but
surprisingly not as much as I thought
Hannah Montana based on the mid 2000
show I've never seen seems to follow the
double life of a girl named Miley she
turned out to be a singing worldwide
phenomenon but her father Robby ray
played by Miley Cyrus is dead Billy Ray
Cyrus thinks it's unhealthy for someone
so young to be in the spotlight all the
time so they create an alternate
personality because that's much more
healthy right
that won't mess up a kid at all in this
kind of scenario it's kind of like Clark
Kent glasses all you need is a wig for
suddenly everyone not to recognize her
at all from that set up alone I guess I
shouldn't be surprised how this movie
opens up it's a Hannah Montana concert
and Miley can't get into her own concert
because no one believes it's her yep
that's the kind of logic this film runs
on of course crazy antics and stunts and
silliness ensue with this constantly
going back and forth between normal life
and celebrity again totally not messing
this girl up at all but when her dad
gets concerned about missing her best
friend's party because she was in a
fight with Tyra Banks okay I gotta admit
that's a little funny he takes her back
to her farm home in the country to
hopefully reconnect with her roots that
means no glamour no riches no press no
Hannah but apparently this tabloid
reporter is following her to get some
dirt on her because her getting in a
fight with Tyra Banks wasn't enough so
we hunt her down to find out some
secrets because the magazine already has
the cover ready they just need to fill
it with a story again that's a little
funny what isn't so funny is every stock
cliche that usually goes along with this
idea she constantly has to go back and
forth between being Anna and being Miley
and what a coincidence there's a big
get-together where she has to either go
on a date with this boy she likes her
she has to stop this big bad mall from
being set up that's gonna destroy her
hometown and well she can't go to both
and camp Cole the boyfriend to push the
time back for some reason
so she has to run back in for changing
outfits and wigs and oh god this is dumb
so yeah this film's written bad like
really really bad but surprisingly it's
not as horrible as you would think maybe
because this was a theatrical release
there's a little bit more time to work
things out because of that the
performances seem rather genuine the
pacing is pretty good the slapstick
isn't too over-the-top there's not a ton
of stupid sound effects it's how do I
put it not like a run-of-the-mill Disney
Channel movie a lot of the film is just
her being on the farm and connecting
with her dad and connecting with his new
boyfriend and her family and trying to
find herself and yeah I know that all
sounds a little lame but if it's done
well it's done well don't get me wrong
there's plenty of corny moments but
there's also a lot of silent moments too
and even when song numbers do pop up it
doesn't seem out of nowhere or too
distracting it kind of fits in the feel
of the rest of the movie yeah she sounds
a little auto-tune and the instruments a
little too professional for the settings
half the time but it's not like camp
rock where suddenly there's a musical
number is not like Jem and the Holograms
where suddenly everyone sounds like it's
not them singing at all it just sounds
so incredibly fake it's just the right
balance of a little corny but kind of
nice too which is kind of a good way to
sum up this movie despite it being
written terribly for example during the
scene where she has to go back and forth
between restaurants during the date and
a big get-together with the mayor the
script calls for her to be changing in a
revolving door and then she runs into
the boyfriend well that's just one of
the mill stupid but here there's kind of
nice music and it's in slow mo and she
sees this little kid who recognizes her
first and she doesn't know how to react
and then suddenly she comes across the
boyfriend who sees her and all of a
sudden everything is hitting her at the
same time it's hitting him and you see
both the reactions and it's actually a
very interesting scene it took a very
silly moment and made it surprisingly
reflective slowing things down seeing
her go in a circle while also seeing her
own reflection can actually be kind of
deep but again for a Hannah Montana
movie this is still a Disney movie
selling a Disney pop star based on a
Disney Channel product but as those go I
can't say it's really bad I can't say
it's good either but it's definitely
better that has
right to be I like that took his time I
like that there's quieter moments I like
that focused on relationships I like
it's not all about the glam and
celebrity in fact the majority isn't
even about that a lot of its just kind
of chilling and farmland getting to know
these unique characters does it have a
lot of Disney Channel movie cliches yes
and do I wish it didn't hell yes but at
the same time they're not done as bad as
you would expect them to be I feel like
the age group this was made for it could
watch it okay and even get a
self-reflecting it'll be a corny journey
out of it and people they grew up with
it can kind of look back and laugh at oh
yeah
the wig is supposed to fool everybody oh
yeah everyone at this concert at the end
is supposed to just be quiet and not
reveal her secret I guess after seeing
so many horrible movies about bands
based around kids like Cheetah Girls and
the camp rock movies I don't really see
this as that offensive if you don't like
Hannah Montana and you're looking for
things wrong with it you'll get a
buttload buff your kid and like the show
or even nostalgic and want to take a
happy look back this is a fond enough
memory
[Music]
you